vendredi la colère samedi le
recueillement ce samedi plusieurs
milliers d'habitants de erevan se sont
retrouvés sur la place de la liberté
pour entamer une marche silencieuse dans
les rues de la capitale en tenant des
bougies des croix des drapeaux en
mémoire des soldats morts dans le
haut-karabagh hier entre 1500 et 2000
personnes s'étaient déjà rassemblées
sans débordement plutôt que de chercher
une quelconque confrontation avec les
forces de l'ordre on a pu constater que
les habitants de yerevan étaient
descendus dans la rue pour crier leur
colère et leur incompréhension après la
prise de décision du premier ministre
arménien nicole pas de signal de signer
le cessez-le-feu avec l'azerbaïdjan sous
l'égide de moscou les manifestants
scandaient notamment le slogan pas de
xi'an traître et considère effectivement
ce cessez le feu comme une trahison et
un abandon par les autorités arméniennes
du haut karabakh au radar or il n'ya pas
d'autres mots pour celui qui a
secrètement à bord d'une autre terre il
a trahi et doit s'en aller car nous
sommes ici aujourd'hui pour protéger les
frontières de notre pays afin que notre
ennemi n'envahissent pas notre arménie
après cette signature
après le transfert du karabagh nous
serons aux côtés de notre pays et
soutiendront les gens avec tout ce que
nous pourrons
le mieux essayer mais marc fesneau je
suis venu dire que pashinian devrait
obtenir des négociations qui conviennent
mieux à nos intérêts et que ce qui a été
perdu pour l'arménie devrait être
récupérée et s'il ne peut pas y parvenir
alors il doit partir le haut karabagh
l'atsa dans sa version officielle est un
territoire où vivent cent cinquante
mille personnes 95 % d'entre elles sont
des arméniens durant la période
soviétique ce territoire était intégrée
à la république socialiste d'azerbaidjan
c'est pourquoi en 1991 après la
dislocation de l'urss l'arménie a voulu
récupérer ce territoire peuplé en
majorité par des arméniens s'en est
suivi un conflit sanglant qui s'est
officiellement terminée en 1994 grâce à
un accord de paix signé encore une fois
avec l'appui de la russie et ce
cessez-le-feu
aujourd'hui est vécue par les arméniens
comme une capitulation puisque trois
quarts du territoire a été rétrocédée en
azerbaïdjan c'est un conflit qui dure
depuis plus de 30 ans et les arméniens
ont vraiment un sentiment de
capitulation pourtant le premier
ministre a fait savoir que la décision
du cessez-le-feu n'était pas justement
une capitulation mais qu'elle avait été
prise en tenant compte de facteurs
complexes et dans le but de préserver la
sécurité du peuple arménien une sécurité
qui dans le haut-karabagh sera désormais
assurée par moscou le président russe
vladimir poutine s'est exprimé vendredi
à ce sujet pour lui un véritable bain de
sang a été évité et samedi dans la
journée le commandant des forces russes
du maintien de la paix dans le haut
karabagh a fait état de la situation sur
place
les accords signés par les trois chefs
d'état entré en vigueur le 10 novembre à
partir de minuit sont aujourd'hui
pleinement mises en oeuvre
le plus important c'est que toutes les
actions militaires sur le territoire de
contacts ont été arrêtés aujourd'hui
nous n'entendons plus de coups de feu la
situation se stabilise petit à petit la
base du contingent de maintien de la
paix des forces armées de la fédération
de russie est constitué de la 15e
brigade d'infanterie motorisée le
personnel a suivi une formation spéciale
certaines activités pratiques ont été
menées en rapport au maintien de la paix
la 15e brigade indépendante d'infanterie
motorisée de maintien de la paix du
district
militaire centrale comme gelée
soulignait achève aujourd'hui
complètement le processus de déploiement
de tous les postes d'observation le long
de la ligne de contact
ce n'est pas pour autant que les
habitants de yerevan acceptent ces
décisions aujourd'hui il était donc
plusieurs milliers à entamer une marche
silencieuse dans les rues de yerevan
pour honorer les morts dans le
haut-karabagh